[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
standing right now in bedford
outside this fabulous house of one of my
students alistair cunningham
who's built a massive property portfolio
this is just one of his deals
i'm going to walk you through it and
show you exactly how much you paid for
it
how much you spent on the refurb how
much is worth now how much is written
out for
you get to reveal everything right now
in this video and learn to do the exact
same thing as well so let's go
ma'am so this is the man the myth the
legend literally
packet you're like one of the biggest
deal sources in the uk
yeah well we try so what alexter does is
he packages up properties
and then he passes them on to investors
how many deals have you done like that
uh wow well in the last 12 months over
200 200
last 12 months however when you're
packaging deals and selling them that's
making you a lot of money
yeah but then would you do the very best
deals best deals and keep them ourselves
right
so this is one you kept for yourself
yeah and presumably
you bought it with the money that you
made from packaging yeah it comes from a
mixture of bridging and
packaging selling deals money yeah and
this was a deal that i found when i was
like actually looking for investors so
yeah um yeah well let's look round yeah
some kitchen um all right
so very very nice for the live huge
isn't it my
very open nothing like it was
no when i so when i got this there was a
big wall down here this was two separate
rooms
um and it was actually really small and
compressed
the kitchen was that side it was just
that literally that there
and so we knocked this main wall down we
opened it all up
uh and we put massive kitchen in um it's
actually really yes come on i'm really
happy about it's finished now an
interesting thing about this house
is those serious structural problems
with the house
and as a result no one wanted to touch
it with a barge pole yeah everyone was
running away from it but you
obviously knowing what you know your
experience on property and doing so many
deals
um you saw opportunity yeah um well
the agent told me that i was the 44th
person that viewed this house 43 other
people have been reviewing
44th person yeah it'd been on the market
for about
six months and i couldn't believe that
i've missed it i was so annoyed that i'd
actually
not spotted it so you're so crazy about
that
you you think for a good deal yeah you
need to be off-market
no yes but this was not only on the
market but also no one cared about it no
people were coming and viewing it and
leaving now the reason they were leaving
was because when
when i viewed it the first thing the
agent said her name was jane
she said before you view it there's a a
buyer's pack
and it's got in there or an estimate
from a local company because to fix the
structural issues
now that estimate they were gonna have
to dig the garden up they're gonna have
to
redo the footings they're gonna have to
do all sorts of structural issues
uh and it was coming to about thirty six
thousand pounds twenty nine thousand
plus that
yeah 36k and i look today and i'm like
dig up the footings i'm gonna come on
really
um and it turns out that the extension
was built
without planning basically yeah but it'd
be not here for quite quite a bit of
time that hadn't been done very well
so with with my network and with people
i know from academy
have had me trainers and things like
that i've reached out to our senior
architect we've gotten
on the training and i'm like hey man
that's what you think
and he literally laughed at it he said
that's just ridiculous you don't need to
do it
how much to make how much did he say uh
so he he said there would be no one here
he said it'll probably be
10 grand max yeah but i actually got the
whole all the structural fix all the
structural issues
the structural beam calculations the new
beams we had to put a 15 foot beam
upstairs
and i've done all of that for less than
four grand less than
four so the seller was an idiot they
should have just fixed it themselves
yeah but they didn't know how
yeah because they didn't have the
training they didn't have the network so
the story behind this is owned by it was
owned by a local housing authority
okay and they have tenants in here
they've been here for 10 years
and the tenants trashed the place okay
so the tenants stole
the boiler right they stole all the
radiators who would do that
so i don't know mate so when i what do
you want to do i don't
when i got this house there was no
radiators all the pipes were bent
up the the boiler was missing um and
when i started when i the day i got this
has they got the keys to come in
and the lady from next door coming and
knocked on the door and she went
are you my new are you the new owner and
i'm like yeah and her name is pat and
she's a lovely old lady
and she was petrified because she's had
10 years of hell
yeah and she was like
i just wanted to see make sure you see
what you're about because like we've had
a nightmare from the people been living
here yeah
and like if you even if you look on
google there you can see them out the
front
drinking on the front and honestly it's
it's horrendous but the thing is that in
buy this you've made a lot of money
right he's made yeah
six-figure profit on this we're going to
get into the figures later but you've
actually
restored a property that was run down
yeah draining the economy
ruining the area scaring the neighbors
so you've
helped lift it you've also created a
fabulous product because you're not
renting this house out as a whole house
no hitchhiking you're renting a house
can you show up coming from yeah
look at the rooms you've turned into a
five-bed hmo
nice yeah love it every time i've ever
been in one of your houses you always do
it the exact same colors yeah green
white
everything is grey and white is that is
that something to do with your
personality or
yeah what
is it no no do you know i i think it's
just really modern it just works
i think it's really modern um i like
dark colors and woodworking stuff like
that because
it hides marks um i just like the
contrast of green white and plus because
i've got multiple properties
it's easy because then it's it's i can
just tell the builder this is the gray
this is the
white everything's the same everything's
the same has every room gone on suite
every room double on suites apart from
number two
it's still got an off sweep but it still
goes individual
how much how much rent cause this is
just finished right just being finished
you've already got a tenant moving into
this i've got tenant moving in first of
all
seven seven five did you hear that sorry
sorry
sorry seven seven five seven seven five
for a room
for this one because you not just rent
an entire house for that not in this
area
okay in bed for sure what's what you
gotta look at what the options for the
people okay
the people moving in here is gonna be a
girlfriend boyfriend they're moving from
manchester
to study medicine they're gonna be here
for a year they want it from the first
of september to the end of july next
year
um and they their options are have a hmo
where bills are included
furniture is included they've got a nice
beautiful house
they've got access to the whole house
apart from all the bedrooms for 775 or
they can go and rent a studio
apartment for about 1100 and pay bills
and
their own firm council tax it's true so
you're creating a fabulous product
it's a product even a lot of like these
kind of things here man
this is nice attention to detail one two
three four five and a spot for alistair
with his food menus
love it yeah and this sort of thing why
did you do this
it's just attention to details that's
all it is it's attention to detail
and it just it means it's quality yeah
because
i go into hmos all the time and this is
what happens you see all the mail
just sat on the side like that and i
don't like it it's clutter
it's messy yeah just the air is on the
floor because i think with five people
you've got five lots of post just keeps
it nice and i bet that didn't cost much
at all pennies i think that was about 18
quid right
with this with it but then it's just
nice
yeah that board yeah where do you get
your bits from um
i don't know i didn't do it my mom did
it oh your mom my mom done it
all for me oh wow um so i don't know
i've probably done elm or something like
that
okay so these doors yeah they are very
head of fire doors yeah
so so that just means if there's a fire
yeah and you're in your room
it's gonna take 30 minutes for the fire
to get through yeah
and then also you've got escape windows
yep so the windows in hmos
have to be big enough for a large man
go and try jump out
yeah so we've got the the proper fire
doors with a five door closer
interlinked fire alarm system above uh
and all the windows in the bedroom's
open more than 90 degrees here's the
thing right
if you are a property investor and you
only read books
and watch youtube videos and you don't
have the full proper training
yeah you don't understand things like
the licensing rules the planning
applications article for you what you've
been so smart with this house
is you've absolutely maximized off of
the rules
so talk to me as we go through yeah
about
talk to me about the rules and how you
have been however with this area with
this house okay
so bedford as of november 2020
yeah article four was enforced last year
they they announced that
in november 2019 yeah so i knew that so
i started looking around bedford yeah
and i found this property towards the
beginning of last year
february march i'm coming exactly just
for coveted yeah um
and i come out and view it but i knew
obviously it wasn't going to be
completed in time for
november so what i'd done was i spoke to
the council and i said look i bought
this property
i used kobit i said look covered causing
massive delays
can i put an application in now before
it's finished
um and will i still go through and she
said yeah no problems i'll stuck an
application in
um just a basic blank application
name the address and i signed and i paid
the fee how much
775 okay um i said no 790
um they were there abouts um i put the
put the application in
and then they've been fine i speak to
her once a month so now
so now planning permission has to be
you need planning permission to do a hmo
yeah now which they're probably going to
say no
yeah right but this has got grandfather
rights
which has pushed the value up also the
competition like how many times how many
times do i have to keep telling people
we we we were both saying this a year
and a half ago we were like
bedford bedford bedford i remember at
the deal finding traffic andrew on stage
so any of you going where
bedford bedford bedford and oh but let's
see
yeah i'm not sure how does it work and
now two lakes suckers
well there's 43 people viewed this too
late i'm the one making the money
and the 43 people that viewed it didn't
buy it because they're worried about
brexit or they're worried about oh we're
going to a lockdown or whatever it might
be or they're worried about
um the structural stuff but it's like
just get the knowledge and do it
properly this is a business if you don't
if you don't get yourself trained
properly folks you're going to get blown
flat in this industry i think most of
the training is free i know it it
baffles me it baffles me it normally
does like this bathroom
yeah they're all i mean the bathrooms
are are compact but they're
they are what they are how much did you
pay for this house
the house and 210 thousand two hundred
and ten grand and when you bought it 210
i mean looking back it's like oh that
was a steal yeah but actually at the
time
210 didn't seem like it still because it
was in a very bad condition wasn't a
very bad condition it was back to brick
in a lot of places had major structural
issues which i'll get to because i saved
tell me about the structure okay um
structural issues in the sense of
the extension was not tied into the main
building uh so there was no structural
steels above there was no lentils
anywhere
and there was quite quite a bit as i
said downstairs i managed to save
a lot so they've done badly um also i
forgot to say downstairs
obviously because this property was
uninhabitable
oh i got me no tax no stamp dream
yeah i've got eight thousand i had to
pay it so i have to pay it because of
the bridge in finance
but i got a refund of eight thousand
pounds towards in the last year
from stanton cherry because i proved
that it was uninhabitable yes
again another education and you know so
man i was uh
the buyer refused we found us last week
nobody knew about that they were like
we didn't know you can get your money
back until the end of the program until
then the program and then
they were like wow now they're all
thinking about
i've got problems i've done last year
that could get the money but the thing
is as well
like the the amount that you paid for
this the amount that you saved on the
structural
yeah on fixing the structural problems
was like 30 grand that's what people say
i mean look the top end training you've
been through now you're one of the lead
trainers yeah
the top end training is about 12 grand
yeah i know
and he was oh it's really expensive that
that's like unlimited mentorship
unlimited coaching all the training
programs for a whole year
full advanced strategies and it's like
look man it's expensive
if you see it as edu entertainment yeah
yeah but if you see us i want to be a
professional property investor
i mean you made them how much do you pay
for the academy uh at the time i paid 60
i paid more
so you made 16 grand but you made that
back on this one deal
probably three four like look again
infinite like yeah
loads what would you say somebody
thinking about investing
in their education if you're gonna
listen if you want to be serious in this
business
then stop [ __ ] a power basically
like if you want to make money because
you you're not going to make hundreds of
thousands of pounds from property use
by having a bash from watching youtube
you're just not um if you don't
stop watching youtube though okay oh it
starts
it starts here but you need to get
trained
yeah i wouldn't have done this deal 43
other people come and done this deal but
they didn't
they didn't they didn't do it because
they didn't have the knowledge they
didn't have the skill set
they didn't have the network they didn't
have the people around them you know the
vision
you have the vision that's nothing down
the vision yeah yeah
so okay so we're one of the full figures
so i bought it for 210.
how much you said it cost you just four
grand for the
structure fixing the structure issues
yeah how much did the entire
refurb everything down to the freaking
cushion
the kitchen everything how much it cost
i added it up all day and it's just
over sixty eight thousand pounds like
sixty eight thousand two hundred and
twenty or something
okay so you spent sixty eight grand on
it you bought it for two
ten that means that in total you're
talking about two seven eight
no yeah no stamp duty no it comes back
you got it back 100
back yeah you funded it with money that
you were making
as a deal saucer you pulled in a couple
of uh private uh
joint venture private angel investors
yeah so yeah and you've got bridging
finance so purchase the purchase was
my finance that i have acquired myself
from dale's old-sourcing
and then i got bridge in finance and
then i pulled in our investor to help
with the refurb okay and he won four
all right which by the way anyone can do
that of course anyone can do that so you
put 278 in
total yeah how much
is it worth right now uh right now
i was expecting it to be valued at 350
because that's what it was that's what
they're bridging
which would be a decent deal even still
decent 72 grand profit
but it was valued last tuesday by
cornell's who value for kent reliance at
hundred thousand pounds oh
four hundred grand okay and that's the
thing property's been going up
yeah yeah so okay nuts and you you've
now got the choice are you gonna sell it
or are you gonna refinance it well
i've got both options here corners are
going to market it for six weeks at no
cost to me
so i've said you market it if you can
get um an offer
then i'll consider it they've all i've
already had offers off asking price at
400 000 and i've turned them down
because i want to wait six oh
dude and just see what happens with the
the banter i'm so happy to hear this
um but i've also got one uh refinance
yeah
uh um if you i would probably be fine
that's it
yeah no no i probably will go that way
if you sell it you're gonna spend
capital gains tax
and you're gonna lose the income because
this battle is renting out for fortune
we'll get to that all right so look four
hundred thousand
so other if you refinance it yeah you're
gonna pull out 75 percent of
400 which is 300 000 yeah you only put
in 278
so you're pulling out all of your money
yeah
plus having 22 000 pounds in your pocket
which is just in i know it's not it's
absolutely not
it's 122 000 pounds clean profit then it
gives me infinite return for the rent so
my preferred option
yeah is to keep refinance rent out okay
that's what we teach
however i have got a couple more deals
in the pipeline they need them that
might need the money fair enough which
will make a lot more money
rent yeah you've just finished i'm one
of the first people to see this fully
finished you are yeah
you've already got two two two two rooms
two rooms three tenants two rooms three
tenants and it's not even
you're just still doing the snagging
right now how much
rent are you getting on these rooms okay
so this rumor in a minute is gonna be
6.50
uh every other room apart from
downstairs is 700 and then downstairs is
775.
dude man so the rent on that is what
three five
there are yeah three four fifty or
something about about three
almost three and a half thousand pounds
but if you've got a mortgage of three
hundred here's the crazy thing
you only watch the interest what
interesting is it it's just under four
percent so it's the mortgage is about
900
a month 940. call it four percent yeah
divided by 12 1 000 but yeah it's 99. so
about 980. so you're going to be paying
980 a month
interest payments yeah but then you're
renting it for three and a half
you know what that's called that's
called financial freedom in one deal
in one day now as it happens you've
already got loads of deals yeah but
right
but if you were starting all over again
yeah and you just did this
financial freedom this is the thing that
we we teach people at the academy
like how many deals you need to become
financially free for the majority of
people in the uk
this deal one deal yeah i'm going to be
making around 1800 to 2000
a month profit on this deal that in
itself is financial freedom for
a lot of people yeah but certainly a lot
a long way towards
it um you were because for everyone
doesn't know
alistair went through the academy some
years ago yeah watches winners on the
wednesday story it's remarkable came on
it came on the academy then became
financially free came on winners on a
wednesday then came out in 2018 to
africa helped out with the charity works
yeah me and erin are really close
friends
he's actually one of our lead trainers
on the academy as a part of your mission
to give back that's why he's here he
doesn't have to do a video with us today
he could be like hey
i don't want to share all my all the
secrets and everything but alistair
is like hey i've become financially free
and now i want to share i want to
inspire i want to show that i'll see the
same thing
you were at the brr last week which we
ran together yeah and you mentioned
something that i was saying about big
deals and small deals
yeah do you know um one of the things
that one of the
every deal you do will have hiccups will
have good things bad things okay
one of the problems i had with this deal
was we had problems with some of the
builders
i'm just managing them with through not
not been able to have more than one or
two trades in the building anytime it's
caused lots of delays
um so one thing you mentioned was big
deal small deals the the difference is
project management right with a big deal
you can you've got the money because the
profit margin you've got the money to
just say
25 30 grand you're the project manager
you deal with it i'm just going to come
and do videos okay
um and yeah i was sitting in the back of
the room last week listening to you say
that
and i actually i don't like i i not been
funny man i hear you speak all the time
so i know what you generally what you
said i know the syntax right
but then you said that and i'm like yeah
and i'm like taking notes and it's
it's um yeah it made me sit up and think
geez he's [ __ ] bang on the money
there bang on the money
and then like i made the decision when i
bought this
this is probably going to be my last
sort of house like this unless it's got
potential like this
so basically what you're saying is you
want to move on to bigger deals now
isn't it funny that alistair thinks this
is a small deal even though he's made
over 100 grand profit
he thinks it's a small deal that's what
happens when you've been in the in the
game for a few years
love it oh look at this i've seen i've
seen the pictures of what the background
i've never
never i've never been to this house in
person by the way first time i've ever
been here in the flesh
but i have seen pictures this was a
wreck it was um all the fences were down
front back and side this was our just i
was honestly the guard was as high as
the fences
right um so i just got builder in here
they brought the minifigure if you want
to learn how to
do deals like this okay you can continue
watching youtube videos that's awesome
i would highly suggest on the house
come down and get trained come and meet
me come and meet my man out
and and start getting trained so uh
would you what would you say final piece
of advice to someone watching this just
stop messing about
get trained listen we're going across
the country
you've got the property investors crash
course you've got property millionaire
intensive get
along it's not it costs nothing to come
apart from your time but you will learn
the skills to do exactly what i've just
done here
and you could be in a very short period
of time making the same sort of money
that i've made from this deal okay so
my word get trained every week man
winners on a wednesday every week
um maybe i don't know maybe one day
you'll be financially free you'll be
doing big deals you'll be out
coming to africa you'll be on the on the
camera like alistair
when you're successful it's really
important to give back and help others
have mad respect for you doing that
alistair has become an incredible human
being not that he wasn't before
but a better we i used to come to
skeptical scott because he sat at the
back of the room with the crash course
like
hmm all skeptical right now he was the
biggest skeptic
he'd been one of those people probably
disliking the videos i'm not sure oh no
i'm not like that
but i was definitely you weren't hiding
no no i was never here no no but i was
definitely the person at the back of the
room saying
yeah yeah he's making it sound too easy
yeah yeah yeah whatever
but i realized very quickly
that when somebody walks the walk they
can make it sound easy because they do
it and they want to make it sound easy
so you
you learn and you absorb and that's
exactly what someone's a master at
we make we make property look easy in
the same way that beckham makes it look
easy to bend the ball right we're good
at it we've done it a lot of times so
yeah it looks simple but it is simple
when you've learned the rope so if you
want to come down to training
i'd suggest you do that i'll leave a
little link right here get down i'll
leave
details in the description if you want
to subscribe to the channel see more
videos like this there's a lot more good
stuff coming soon subscribe
and if you want to hear alex there's
full story do it right here
over his face yeah and guys i'll see you
next time peace out
you